this is what Trump this is what Trump
had to say here so everyone gets the
full context in a tweet from citizens
for ethics they say in this horrifying
clip Donald Trump proposes Thug
reporters in jail where they'll be raped
until they give up their sources his
crowd left here we go you know in this
country oh wait wait I see I always do
that yeah every single time and it's
because we're listening to the debate
earlier but here you go
to play made public you know in this
country they leak all over the place
even on the Supreme Court by the way you
have to find the leaker of the Supreme
you have to find the liquor you know how
you find the Linker they'll say oh this
is treasonous what I said so they can't
find the leaker he leaked all about row
v Wade look this person leaked from the
Supreme Court never happened you know
how you find but they don't want to
mention this because they think it's so
terrible you take the writer
because you're never going to find
another going through phone records it's
been a long time you take the writer and
or the publisher of the paper a certain
paper that you know and you say who is
the leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they say it's okay you're going to jail
and when this person realizes that he is
going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly
he will say I'd very much like to uh
tell you exactly who that leaker it was
Bill Jones I swear he's a liquor and we
got him but they don't want to do that
they don't want to do that but that's
the only way you're going to find we
have to find can you imagine they leak
so I'll just point out first and
foremost that we need prison reform
because the idea that you get locked up
and rape is a threat against you I think
that violates which amendment is that
cruel and unusual punishment yes yes
yeah I don't know the idea that in our
society it is normal and expected and
believed that's the case is like okay
that's that's cruel unusual punishment
well if anything then the leaker should
just be charged with treason and then
you know well it's guilty or not guilty
it would be sedition not just
accordingly so uh uh just just to be
specific sedition they already know who
who the leaker is anyway like let's stop
they know who the leaker is they know
who the Gen sex bomber is they knew who
all those people are they just don't
want to do anything about it because
it's on their side I mean they have
total information surveillance they have
the NSA that literally watches almost
every little thing you do and they're
playing stupid here that's that's a
point to make here Trump's comments here
are atrocious and again leakers
whistleblowers serious yeah I think it's
fair we all make like f'd up jokes
behind closed doors he just says it in
the open I I think that's a larger point
that I was going to make here as I said
his comments are okay you can but but
his comments are atrocious I I think
what this country has done to leakers
and whistleblowers is immoral but when
you look at his administration it was
filled with leakers and he didn't do
anything when you look at the Obama
Administration he was very heavy-handed
on leakers threw them in jail and used
the Espionage Act against them Trump
didn't even go that far but these
comments are are bombastic these
comments are Are Over The Line yeah
that's why I agree with Mary that
Trump's obviously joking because he did
not go after these people in this way
Obama did Obama arrested journalists
literally and Trump is is only making
gross comments about a resting Journey
but then we have the you know Julian
Assange that's true Julian Assange is a
leaker and no no he's not a junior he
was a journalist who was helping leakers
release information
um and this is the person that Trump
would take in jail and essentially have
you know what what he said there let's
and you if you look at you know Julian
Assange Donald Trump said that he was a
hero a couple years ago now he acts like
he doesn't know who he is and the reason
that he failed to Pardon him According
to some sources according to the
information that that we've got was
because Julian Assange wouldn't leak who
was the source of the information when
it came to a lot of the Hillary Clinton
emails and because of that Donald Trump
and because of the pushing by Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump didn't pardon
Julian Assange and decided to do Kodak
Black so I just want to you know clarify
that point Point Barack Obama the
president before Trump locked up
journalists locked up whistleblowers
spied on them spied on a spied on them
Adam Schiff released the private phone
records of John Solomon and Donald Trump
said nasty things
I don't like that Trump said these nasty
things I think it's it's a scary thing
to say but you've got all these leftists
that are like he's so evil well how come
these people vote for him and I'm like
bro you voted for Obama Obama went after
that Fox news reporter like more than
once who was that guy do you remember
that guy
um James ryzen was that his name I think
so yeah
so come on we also have uh other stories
that I'll that I'll I'll leave more
Vegas
like the the bark is lighter than the
bite like do you really want he's always
been that way yeah like he doesn't he
doesn't really come down as harshly as
you'd want him to
um a lot of times and I'm not saying
that I agree with what he said because I
don't but it's always been that he has a
pension for hyperbole I feel like it's a
Northeast thing and like the the rest of
the world doesn't seem to like get that
he also doesn't do favors for the people
that you want him to do favors for the
reason that he pardoned those rappers is
essentially that like he is obsessed
with being liked being popular he comes
from the entertainment industry that's
what he's about and it shows right so
you guys going to vote for Trump 2024
yep yes
you know being a part of a divide and
conquer system not being a part of it I
don't have a system that of course again
it depends who's running first of all uh
who's out there if Dave Smith is out
there if Peto Peter's out there if if
Ron DeSantis is out there it's a big
thing but obviously I've criticized
Donald Trump uh I criticized his
connections to Henry Kissinger John
Bolton I think anyone in power needs to
be held accountable I think he failed in
a lot of his policies he was different
he shuffled things up he definitely
rattled some parts of the establishment
but he definitely coddled another part
of the establishment and I think uh we
could do a lot better and when someone
is ego focused we do better I think so I
think we could absolutely do a lot
better I think I think there's a lot of
potential he had the experience issue he
didn't have the right people surrounding
him I think that you know years in there
will help that the Santa seems like the
better fit because he has the experience
or he did but he has that under his belt
now and I think that he would be a
little more cautious and look back and
see what he he's done wrong and Surround
himself with better people this time and
actually listen Maybe I mean seeing
these comments and and then seeing what
he says about the vaccine seeing how
he's I didn't like the vaccine seeing
him just coddle the big Pharma and and
criticized people who are against it
that right there should highlight
something
um and and along with you know just all
the other things he did before it makes
you really wonderful about the vaccine
that was still about Trump and his ego
it's all it's it's not being able to
admit that he might be wrong but he
doesn't he doesn't want to admit hiring
people like Bolton bringing him on I
mean we wanted to have Bill Gates as a
science advisor okay that that's that's
a huge red flag for me and and as soon
as you're trying to get Bill Gates in
positions of power in government to
regulate things in your life you're
going to have some problems so I don't
think Rhonda Sanders will run against
Trump he will I don't think he will
either I absolutely think he will only
run if Trump doesn't if there's like a
hole to fill there I would I would I
would probably I would rather vote for
DeSantis but if the issue is you know if
it's between Trump and his hands and
they're both running then I'd just be
like well it's a coin toss between the
two and if it's Trump and nobody else
it's Trump I'm not I mean Trump's saying
he's going to fire all these bureaucrats
or try to that was a schedule left stuff
I mean certainly not going to be a
Democrat what do they even stand for
claiming they want to end fossil fuels
and then begging the Saudis for oil
there's no platform there at the very
least Republicans are like we don't like
the wokeness in the government and I'm
like okay those things are illegal and
they shouldn't be there anyway at least
I can vote for that
no Wars under Trump no problem just for
the record I have no problem criticizing
Donald Trump I criticized him in a video
like a long one about the two thousand
dollar stimulus that was pathetic that
he was advocating for that that was like
really bad there's there's a lot of
things that I didn't agree that he that
he did but I think that overall it was
better than any of the Alternatives I
wanted Rand Paul originally people yeah
people are saying unsubscribe from Luke
uncensored that's fine that's okay and
I've been expressing these opinions from
the very beginning I'm seeing the
comments I read all the comments all the
time I'm not here I'm not here just just
to please people in the comment section
I have my own thoughts and I'm not here
to just go along with the group think
and I think it's important to challenge
certain narratives yes ghost girl with
your little psy here it's important to
question things it's important to to
question anyone in Authority especially
when there's so much that you could go
back on you could say and I don't want
to be that person that says oh you could
just go back and criticize everything no
no no it's important to hold people's
feet to the fire including when they do
things that actually hurt people and
when the Trump Administration brought in
the two weeks to slow the spread when
they brought in Dr fauci when they
brought in operation fast uh warp speed
that they caused a lot of irrevocable
damage to society to this country when
they started handing out checks to
random individuals that's a problem
right there all right and if you're not
willing to hold your own party
accountable you're not willing to be the
best party uh that there could be and
yes other parties absolute crap but I
don't want to choose between one piece
of dog crap and another piece of horse
crap but that's just me personally all
right but hold on hold on right now
between the two of you what what Lisa is
saying is Trump made a lot of mistakes I
agree with you but I think he's learned
from those and he's he's expressed that
he has and you're saying he made
mistakes therefore he's irredeemable no
uh I don't think he he redeemed himself
on those mistakes if he comes forward
and says hey guys you know maybe you
know putting fauci in power maybe doing
operation warp speed I thought she was
already there he could have fired him
what he what is Trump saying right now
about the vaccine that's an important
aspect here right that that's that plays
along into a lot of different things and
what he's saying right now I can't even
mention here probably on this show but
but but there there should be a larger
debate about that specific issue that
should be a warning sign to everyone let
me ask you guys do you think the
Republicans
if they win every every branch do you
think they will ban abortion Nationwide
oh I don't think they should
put it I think they should in the next
that's do you think they will in the
next four
2024. it's uh November well I don't know
the election day is going to follow
November Donald Trump wins to Gap
presidency the Republicans secure the
hold on uh the house the Senate they got
the Supreme Court six to three Trump
wins the presidency and now they have
the path cleared before them do you
think the ban abortion Nationwide 27-28
possibility yeah after those midterms
yep after those midterms I don't know
though because historically it would be
a Democrat flip so they'd have to do it
before it's actually more only
historically a Democrat flip when
there's a Democrat president
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there